Kings Indians coming
confession
I guess having plenty for you might as
well get this one out of the way so I
mean having played h3 you might as well
get j4 all the way and let's put a rock
on g1
just to discourage
let's see maybe h4 is gonna be fine
okay let's get going
I might have been a bit careless here
anyway Gogi firemen see what happens
okay what the hell let's have some fun
at least I should get some lot of pieces
there now okay
think I can ignore this so I will go
here
and I think I can keep ignoring it
so let's go with that
you
[Music]
this is not going well yeah
the blacks problem is simply as no
square for that vision so he had to play
hit six instead
the Queen h5
yeah it's a pity that the game is just
over in one move but I've already got le
decent compensation I'm not completely
sure of g4 he4 was correct after night
h4 maybe h5 is possible so it was a bit
of a gamble on my part but
I'm winning the Queen or the vision he
left me about six which is obviously no
one's idea of a dream okay I'll take
with the crown and we're in thousand and
ij6 check as well so I go King Eko
like night so this one's handy yeah
and that should clinch it so thank you